hey man it's silly room man check me out
on the bootleg cab podcast ASAP
podcast special guest in here Sally Rue
my boy welcome what's going on what's
going on man chilling chilling well
first of all for people who don't know
uh where are you from how long you've
been rapping you've obviously been doing
your thing for a very long time long
time I'm from East Sacramento Lincoln
Village is out there in Rancho Cordova
uh I've been rapping since I was 15. I'm
32 right now so so you've been at it oh
can we get you closer to the mic if you
don't mind please
um so yeah [ __ ] that's 17 years of
rapping yeah sure and I was rapping
before that but that's when I first
recorded right I got I've been trying to
rap like my whole life for real what um
do you remember like uh when you first
kind of realized you could kind of make
a living off of rap music or like get
some serious money doing this [ __ ]
when was that
that was about 12 years ago now
uh
what was that was that prior to him
getting because there's the time he got
locked up and then when he got like I
every time I talked like we've talked
like he's like yo there was a time he
went to prison and it really kind of
like made him readjust the way he
thought about his music career that was
before that okay so it was before that
yeah
so he was he was gonna buy his other
name
so once you guys Linked UP what was the
difference in terms of like you sent me
out of uh with the CD Baby [ __ ] so I
never I just was putting my [ __ ] on Hulk
share just on the on the [ __ ]
download sites yeah just download Z
share and I'll Hulk sharing all that
[ __ ] yeah all that type of [ __ ] yeah
by then he told me how to do the CD Baby
[ __ ] yeah cause CD Baby was kind of like
the OG version of like what Empire does
now yeah what's you know it's like a way
to get your [ __ ]
yeah I'm just gonna check on another day
but uh
yeah that's what I was [ __ ] with I
did that I did the little CD Baby I made
my first little 300. that was a lot
because I ain't never been on of course
so I'm like oh [ __ ] so I was really that
made me just start dropping [ __ ] more on
there hmm I built my little [ __ ] up over
the time I was gonna say like that's one
thing that um I think that like mozzie
has done successfully over the years is
just like build up an independent
catalog for sure whether it's like doing
random collab projects with like a gun
play or a burner or whatever it is but
just continuing to just rack up catalogs
that's something that you kind of also
took from him for sure yeah sure I've
been I was dropping a hell of projects
like that but I'd be trying to I'd be
trying to keep up at the same time but
he'd be moving he was moving too fast at
the time yeah so and then I was going in
and out of jail so I was I was held back
by that too yeah I saw on Instagram you
said that you had been on probation you
got off in 2020 but you were on
probation since you were 12 years old
yeah because you know
for you to do now is you go to jail for
anything you'd be out out the curfew you
go to jail violation so like every time
you go to jail it start your [ __ ] over
so I never got my [ __ ] right until I got
so the whole time just every time you
get hit for some random [ __ ] they would
just be like reset anything you know and
then I'll get a gun case you know should
that make sense right I get a gun case
back then weed charges it's a little
certain [ __ ] like that and it'll just
keeps starting over starting over I
think the last time I went to the county
was like
two thousand 2014 probably 15 or 14.
because how long was were you originally
supposed to be on papers I think the
first time when I was 12 was like
three years or five years what did you
do at 12 to get you on that again oh at
12 years old I was in the stolen core
were you driving the strolling car at 12
I even know how to drive I stole it but
I ain't I wasn't driving I didn't know
how to drive at the time he had an
interesting uh sixth grade year huh yeah
that was crazy I lost my virginity at
night
Howard was the girl she was 15. okay I
lied though I thought I was 13.
so you lost your virginity at nine years
old you get arrested for stealing a car
and having a gun on you at 12.
my goodness man
do you have do you still like see the
girl you lost your virginity online ever
yeah I've seen her on there how she look
now
she doesn't look like uh my type of girl
yeah it's funny because like I'll see
like when I was like 11 or 12 like
people had crushes on when I was a kid
and then like they pop up on Facebook
and I'm like [ __ ] if I see anybody I
crush on unless they lost it
they still like it's still good they
still look good not me man these [ __ ]
I was [ __ ] with in Arizona
30 kids it's only got some bad [ __ ]
of course not just me when I was like a
little kid man there was always like a
like my I had like family friends like
my my dad's uh Boss's Daughter I used to
like and like now she's just like she's
ran it's bad and when you're a kid
though you only you you like what you
accessible to facts you don't know
nothing about all these other people who
knows your daughters I mean your friends
daughter your dad's friend's daughter
right that's all you know so you don't
know what looks better than that right
you know this is a girl what up y'all we
gotta stop the interview real quick tell
you about our partners at my bookie man
look it's so much to gamble on right now
we got World Cup soccer we got bowl
games coming up NBA basketball uh of
course NFL man we're getting into the
playoffs in a few weeks well in like six
weeks or something like that uh with
that being said let's win some money all
right go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg and they
will match your deposit up to a thousand
dollars that's free money to gamble with
that's free money what are we talking
about about my bookie uh let's talk
about the props you could bet on all
kinds of player props NBA points uh well
Giannis win MVP you can do Futures on
the awards season for the NBA uh so much
going on you could also still bet on the
NFL MVP odds as well there's just so
much ways to get money on my bookie but
what's most important is that they're
giving you free money you sign up at my
bookie right now you use the promo code
bootleg and they won't match your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars that's
right free money what are we doing head
over there put in some bets and let's
try to win some [ __ ] money together
all right my bookie use the promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
so when you're [ __ ] a nine how long
you last bro it didn't last long because
uh my brother walked in I'm gonna say
you're are you like did you you did you
finish no I didn't I didn't mean she
kept saying don't come don't come I am I
even know what kind of weather at the
time I'm like [ __ ]
did she have to like kind of show you
what to do no no you knew I was watching
pornos and [ __ ] Jesus Christ it's just
nine just [ __ ] you were watching VHS
tapes
for sure DVDs yeah Booty Talk number 78
starring [ __ ] Pinky or [ __ ] uh
pinky pinky was after yeah I'm about to
say piggy was definitely after back then
I don't even know that's like you know
who was the uh what was the girl's name
uh
the OG uh Heather Hunter do you remember
her
she was like you sound familiar but uh I
would I don't know the names like that I
know pinky for sure but yeah pinkies I
don't know she's also a [ __ ] yeah I
think she's a daughter before she is so
short yeah she's a dwarf
she's somebody who the years haven't
been great to either I just saw her
recently Jesus Christ uh uh so you you
[ __ ] at nine you don't finish your
friend is your friend or your cousin
interrupts who interrupted my brother
your brother interrupted you want to set
it up did he come in and finish the job
no no she was she was done ugh
it's funny though because uh he he was
in Middle School I was in elementary but
I didn't go to school I was at my dad's
house for the day he told me to come
walk up to a school pick him up because
it was down the street yeah I wanted to
pick him up and he's like all the girls
gonna like you so when they said oh he's
so cute this is your brother and I'm
like yeah they're like how old is you my
mom 13. I go to Einstein's to school
that I end up going to right but I knew
but you weren't in there yet yeah yeah
so I go to Einstein from 13. I was like
oh he's so cute [ __ ] Summer's come the
summer come that one of the girls come
over every day we play truth dare ah
yeah so start off touching start off
each day got more crazier and the last
there was [ __ ] last day my brother she
went to the bathroom my brother like if
I did you want me to dare to [ __ ] you
I'm like yeah and at the time he had
version two he's six years older than me
right everything he my dad never let him
leave the house without me so everything
he learned for the first time it did for
the first time I did right so anyway I'm
gonna dare to [ __ ] my heart she came
back and he's like if I dare you to [ __ ]
myself uh will you and she like yeah
she's like all right she had to been
around the block a little huh is that
15. she probably was she was like yeah
no problem give me the nine-year-old she
didn't know I was nine though did she
ever find out now let me tell you though
it's crazy and then uh she won't know
now she never found out but uh after
that my brother walked in for like not
even long like 10 seconds down there
like not long but you got in there I got
in there there's a few pumps yeah bam my
brother walking all right I'm done
uh she put her [ __ ] on and he he trying
to do his [ __ ] she's like nah I like
your brother he told me to go he told me
to go get uh
but one of our friends that live around
the corner and I uh has he just was over
here his mom just picked him up he was
he said he was grounded right so I know
he's bullshitting so and I'm like
grounded he's like now I said he said
come get him so I go outside act like I
leave come in and sit by the door I'm
listening he's like you know you just
[ __ ] a nine-year-old right
I like oh this [ __ ]
so I walk out I mean I open the door I
sit for a minute go out
act like you're coming in I come in and
[ __ ]
and she's like yeah I'm gonna go home
all right she's like you trying to walk
me home oh yeah I walk around she like
your brother said you're nice you know I
might not he's just mad because you
won't let him and she's like oh yeah I
thought that's what it was wow
now she gonna know now she knows that
your brother was telling the truth yeah
for sure okay so
you're obviously a badass kid for sure
that was bad for sure for sure
what were you wrapped up in at 12 where
you had a gun on you and like did you
were you with older people yeah yeah
everybody was everybody I hung out with
was three to five years older okay
everybody so when I was 12 it was 15 17.
so when you get arrested at 12 do your
parents like do they they find out like
what what the charges are and like what
how do they feel about that I mean you
know they mad and [ __ ] but
that's
that's like what was you gonna do you
gonna disown me right you guys you gotta
accept it yeah so I mean they tried
different different things try to keep
me in the house trying to move me
certain places right I'm gonna find my
way right back to the neighborhood right
so
it didn't really do anything and then I
ended up living my grandparents and they
older so you know they're not you could
pull some [ __ ] yeah smoother yeah
damn
so 12 to 30.
let's have a you're on probation for
sure damn yo what up bootleg Kev gotta
interrupt the interview shout out to our
good friends at Blue chew it is cuffing
season it's getting cold as a [ __ ]
outside right now and uh you could
definitely use a little extra
um fellas all right blue chew will have
your dick harder than goddamn
trigonometry all right so if if you
really really you know trying to get
your dick game right trying to make sure
your performance is at an all-time high
go to Bluetooth right now bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg they're gonna
give you a month supply for free that's
right a whole month for free
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free my
friend Adam Wade could use some
Bluetooth that's for sure there he is so
uh this is what it is man it's got the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable pill form it gets
delivered right to your doorstep in
discreet packaging you don't have to go
to the doctor to get Bluetooth it's all
online all right and you get your first
month for free try it out and then thank
me later bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg plus they just dropped the new
blue chew mint chewable which has the
same active ingredients as Levitra and
that should have you [ __ ] rocked up
and socked up bud all right so one more
time bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free
let's get back to the interview
state you couldn't leave the state of
California for 18 years I couldn't but I
did but I wasn't supposed to what the
[ __ ] for sure that [ __ ] is wild bro
that's crazy because like I know like
probation obviously is better than being
in jail but at the same time it's like
it's just a nice way to try to keep you
a part of the system it's easy it's easy
to keep you do anything yeah anything we
don't like but make it Justified to all
right well then you didn't break that
law but you violated probation so when
did you like uh finally say okay
enough's enough I got to stop [ __ ]
around I gotta put a seat belt on I got
to get some car insurance I gotta stop
[ __ ] you know giving them excuses I
didn't get my license so just recently
not that a few years ago so wait I was
driving years out of the license just
riding dirty riding dirty see I was the
same way for a long time like I would
say I probably didn't have car insurance
for like
up until I was like 28. I didn't I ain't
yeah I just never got car insurance I'd
have to get pulled over and then give me
the no insurance ticket and then you
have like until your court date to prove
you have insurance and that'd be the
only time I'd get it I get rentals get
them took
go get another rental bike or get it
took buy another car get it to do the
rental cars have your name like flag now
no cause you know like I never had it in
my name okay I always had somebody get
it from me okay because I didn't have
license oh yeah that's true like yeah
how the [ __ ] you're gonna get a rental
car no license
I had license though uh like a 17. but
they took it they took it and I didn't
have it for a long time so how many
different times you go to jail 12 right
throughout your adult like both from 12
to now how many times have you been
incarcerated
I mean juvenile hall I lived in juvenile
like I never like my whole family is
safe when I get it when I come home I'm
on a Home Pass when I go back to Junior
Hall that's like the house yeah because
I I spent my whole teenage years in June
at home you're just in and out in and
out yeah for dumb [ __ ] just anything
right but uh I didn't go to the jail and
I got older too much too much like that
right uh
I just went probably life I mean it's a
lot to a lot of people but not to the
people to me to compare the people I
know right but probably like four or
five times
to the county
but I never I ain't I ain't never been
to the pen though hey that's good yeah I
don't like the juvenile hall [ __ ] kind
of uh it made it easier to to program as
an adult and know what and not to do and
how to do so you would say that like
juvenile hall helped uh helped you with
a staying out of jail as an adult did it
make you a better Criminal is what
you're saying definitely no no because I
I never was like a criminal I just like
had guns and like I was it was like [ __ ]
that is essential yeah it's crazy
because yeah California they make it so
[ __ ] hard for you to like protect
yourself yeah yeah it's wow it's it's
different it isn't stuff they got way
better going and you're in the [ __ ]
capital
when it comes to any type of gang [ __ ]
or anything do you guys get frustrated
in Sacramento that like people say that
people who aren't from Northern
California just kind of box all in with
the Bay Area uh I mean back because I
hear so many people yo we [ __ ] with
debate man I [ __ ] with Mozzy and I'm
like mozzy's from Sacramento yeah no I
always I'll be the one to correct people
most of the time but I don't I don't get
irritated or nothing because it's we
real close and it's the northern cap we
all won as far as a cop but we are not
the bay uh back in the uh days probably
used to get filled away because you know
it's just a little certain [ __ ] it's
like we our own [ __ ] right stop trying
to call us the little brother right we
our own big brother or what a big dog
whatever our own [ __ ] right so that's
all it was back then but
over the time [ __ ] that's that and then
at the time that's growing up in school
never left Sacramento never been
anywhere
never met a bait a real big [ __ ] unless
they come from out here but then you
don't never know so you're like never
even left sack finally Sacramento until
like Sacramento completely until I was
like because the Bay's like only what
two hours away right 15 yeah but I never
went to the Bay right until I was like
15 my mom moved out there then I went
out there for her but other than that I
never went out there either and started
going out there until I was like 17 18.
wow
hey Sacramento's you know obviously you
guys are [ __ ] killing it and then
a lot of sweeties from Sacramento
I mean they but they put it on the bay
they go back and forth but yeah I heard
she went to Sacramento High School in
Sacramento yeah and yeah I mean you know
shout out to sweetie she's she's lovely
yeah yeah she just came into the show
she smelled great
smelled like a like a candle
like a great candle uh so what do you
got going on right now ma'am so I'm uh
I'm getting ready to drop I got my
project money Family respect from the
drop okay I've been working on that I
probably invested more time than money
in it in terms of just like shooting
videos features Beats Audio times just
trying to put all the right [ __ ]
together and really just taking my time
with it right just not rushing it you
feel like in in the past you will Rush
your projects no not really but this one
I just really sat down and just waited
it's like all right
a couple months all right what's the
best songs right now send them to daybo
see how you feel put that to the side
and then come back later when we're
ready to drop
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our folks at hardean Las
Vegas you see them right there you know
what I mean shout out to hard D Man
shout out to everybody over there it's
the uh illest dispensary in the world
number one they got the craziest
selection of weed you'll ever go to when
you're in Las Vegas there's only one
place to go that's hard in you pull up
you say hey I heard about this place on
the bootleg kept podcast and they're
gonna get you hooked up with some
[ __ ] weed all right so go to Jardine
Las Vegas right now if you're in the
city of uh sin or you're going make sure
you uh you know put it put together a
little hour off to the side to make sure
you go get your nice [ __ ] Harding bag
full of uh just the premium weed all
right and not only that you got to shoot
them a follow Harding underscore Las
Vegas I'm gonna shout them out though
because Harding smells the best the
dispensary is just it's not only the
best dispensary in the world it's the
best smelling dispensary in the world
and look now the bootleg kit podcast
smells like Jardin because I have the
hardine signature scent candle you could
have one too you could go to [ __ ]
Hardy in Las Vegas just saying also make
sure you follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas that is important
you have to follow them because there's
some [ __ ] accounts out there we
appreciate hard Dean when you're in
Vegas pull up go get you some smoke go
get you some edibles go get you some
[ __ ] carts whatever it is they got it
and they got it at the highest quality
it's the only place I'm smoking from
that's hard in Las Vegas let's get back
to the interview
they were and really order sorted out
right who's on the album
I got oh Jeezy
baby money shout out to uh baby money uh
Mazzy Mozzy of course
uh low blood and a little goofy shots a
little blood
I don't wanna forget nobody but I think
that's really it though oh Millie's my
boy my caucasian brother Millie That's
my boy that's my [ __ ] boy I [ __ ] with
them Millie's on there and uh TJ TJ 3K
okay is that to do from Detroit to be
scamming no no what's the guy's name
from Detroit to be scamming his is six
two oh that's what I'm thinking about it
yeah it's similar yeah now shout out to
uh to Millie's Millions is fire
that guy's just stays with a wife beater
and a pair of fresh air forces it'd go
crazy
um so how first of all how's mozzie
doing man he's obviously incarcerated I
mean I I ain't really talked to him
personally but I get his messages so and
I I'm I know how to the people that he
talked to so is he like sending like
texts and [ __ ] in jail and all that well
obviously the legal way right on the
phone yeah and it's a rue I mean
whatever right that's good man because
he's getting out he's got a year right
Dave yeah he got too long yeah it's
crazy man is that like um when you see
someone like Mozzy make that move to go
to like CMG and like go under that
Interscope umbrella as somebody like
yourself who's kind of been doing it
independently this whole time as he was
for so long does it make you kind of
think like what if I went the major
label route as well uh I should yeah I
always been thought like that I wouldn't
mind doing it if it made sense whatever
it makes sense for me I'm not really
picky I'm not really trying to do all
the extra [ __ ] whatever makes the most
sense I [ __ ] with that but yeah yeah let
it make the most time
um we see so many artists nowadays like
unfortunately losing their life in like
the place that they're from right
um
I you know I know you guys have had like
public disputes within the city that if
you want to [ __ ] go through a YouTube
rabbit holes out there but are you
pretty like uh
conscientious about moving around
like like are you still in Sacramento I
go to Sacramento uh a lot but but but
you left Sacramento I don't live in
Sacramento though which is the smart
thing right definitely yeah it'd be I'll
be in jail even if even if I have no
problems I'll be in jail right I think
yeah I think that that's like where a
lot of people make mistakes they were
like yo like yeah it's like it's okay
like you're supposed to want to kind of
grow
sure you're never gonna go being in the
same spot yeah and then like when you
when I came here it's like I come here
they got a lot going on police don't
know who I am by name or face they're
not worried about me they're not gonna
just pull up on me but oh that's I know
let me pull over and see what he's doing
let me see what he got going on let's
see if he got a gun on them today I know
he usually has one wow so in Sacramento
it's like oh I know him probation or not
he's I know him he's the height he's a
gamer whatever right we're gonna pull
him over and just check them out yeah
plus like you also probably have to be a
little bit more like uh I mean you
should be conscientious to your
surroundings everywhere right but like
I'm sure in Sacramento it's at a higher
level definitely not even everywhere
though yeah because like [ __ ] happens
everywhere anywhere
like you can go to a place that you
think is [ __ ] in it they don't they're
gonna prove you wrong ain't that the
truth for sure so yeah anything can
happen anywhere I don't I don't play
anywhere I go
so nowadays if you're
let's say uh someone DMS you right and
they want to do a record
but it's dog [ __ ] it's a terrible song
I'm doing it what's the bag though I
mean whatever my price is I've charged
4K right now so he paid me for a camera
do it God awful song now I'm not I'm
gonna do it I ain't gonna [ __ ] I
might punch in but it's still gonna be
tight you're gonna love it and it's
gonna be better way better than anything
you put on there just no disrespect but
you may not promote it if it's dog [ __ ]
I really don't promote too much of
nothing unless it's like
like my personal people
hey we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our fan our family at Odd
Socks that's right the most comfortable
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
that promo code bootleg and you'll save
20 off Christmas time is it coming and
let me tell you something their Black
Friday sale if you're watching this
before Black Friday you might be
watching it after Black Friday but if
Black Friday hasn't came yet just like
Cyrus hasn't came yet it's been a while
he's on a drought guess what
oddsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
20 off plus whatever the [ __ ] else is
going on with their Black Friday sale
and let me tell you they got some new
licenses we got to talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [ __ ]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview I don't really they
probably would that cost extra if
they're like hey I'll pay you to do the
future but you also gotta post it nah if
I if I like the song or if I uh like we
we did the song Together did the video
right we [ __ ] with each other you
sure love I'll post it I ain't gonna
post it post because I barely post my
[ __ ] like that right when my [ __ ] job I
posted and I didn't forget about going
to the next and I need to stop but yeah
that's what I'll do
do you feel like um because nowadays
like with the music industry like you
know it's there's so much like
there's just so much weird [ __ ] you
gotta kind of do to kind of like promote
your [ __ ] now whether it's like being
all Tick-Tock or you know do you feel
like any resistance like [ __ ] with
that kind of [ __ ] because it's obviously
kind of a weird platform or like I mean
I don't [ __ ] with it you're not on Tick
Tock no doing challenges no
um not even like that though I just the
person I'm like a a dull boring person
I'm not you're not uh listen you went to
jail at 12. yeah but you're not that
adult you was [ __ ] at nine I look I
look like to the people that know me
yeah they're like what the [ __ ] are you
doing right I will look I'll be going
out of my element trying to do things
that ain't me right
still [ __ ] with the Sacramento Kings
huh yeah for sure pretty good this year
they're going crazy right now when you
were growing up
Chris Webber was there vladi divock Mike
Bibby you had white chocolate
the Jason Williams yeah Doug Christie
yeah yeah where uh how much did y'all
really because the Lakers versus Kings
[ __ ] rivalry was so insane I'm still
tripping about the antenna [ __ ] they
[ __ ] you all over everything about
that ring that that y should have been
in the finals at least that year for
sure you're supposed to be in the finals
didn't the referees go to jail for yeah
yeah yes you're supposed to be in the
final she'll let us run that back Tim
Donna he did the same thing with my sons
they [ __ ] over my sons that [ __ ]
yeah do you like tapping with like
obviously I know some some of the guys
on the Grizzlies will like tapping with
some of the local artists like um are
you guys tapping with any of the guys on
the Kings these days uh not personally
I'm pretty sure bro is and [ __ ] but no I
ain't really tempting
who was like the most like when you were
coming up like Marshawn Lynch
Marshawn Lynch wait wait I didn't even
finish my question I just felt like I
knew what you was gonna say go ahead I
was gonna say who was like was there
anybody like as you you guys were coming
up that like was really tapped in with
with the city in terms of the hip-hop
scene and [ __ ] and it doesn't have to be
someone on the team now but just it
could be back in the day it could be
when we was coming up yeah like was it
Zebo Maybe
C Webb making terrible Beats no
Chris Webber has some of the worst
[ __ ] production of all time I can't
think of nobody like that was big yeah
that was like [ __ ] with us at all
nobody I can personally say it might be
somebody else
but me yeah I don't know nobody a big
person that was [ __ ] with underground
none of that right you know the
underground I mean it's crazy because
like that scene and has always been
there in Sacramento like back in the day
when I was growing up it was like
[ __ ]
brother lynches from there right yeah
yeah
seebo yeah he's from
was x-rated from there yeah it's almost
Sacramento right yeah yeah shout out to
x-rated he got out of jail and I think
he's on Strange Music now starting with
tech nine all right so you got this new
album coming
um is there anything else uh that you
got going on man you want to talk about
[ __ ] I mean [ __ ]
I'll just be chilling uh you just be
chilling I'll just be chilling man I
ain't got nothing specific on on the
spot right right now if you would have
told me I could have came with a list
and wrote down
it's okay man next time we gotta we need
a verse yeah I'm gonna come with the
verse because like you would have had me
prepare you would have told me I ain't
gonna lie
no I usually take the rap I'm a blame
table this time because I asked him I
said do you want me to come in the verse
and he's like oh I don't know maybe just
an interview so you know what happened
davo got bougie he got the [ __ ]
veneers he got the eyes he got all the
houses and [ __ ] now this [ __ ] I
remember when I met a big dog different
guy
boom